Believe it or not, you're in the
middle of the Kalahari Desert
in a place that is home to
some of the most diverse
wildlife on the planet.
Here, you can move among them.
They watch you.
They listen to you.
And they can smell you.
Welcome to the Okavango Delta.
This incredible wildlife
coexists within a
balanced ecosystem.
Protecting it has created
a conservation-based
tourism economy for Botswana.
But this oasis is supplied
by water that comes from Angola
through a wider system
that's under threat.
Climate change, deforestation
and commercial agriculture
upstream are putting it at risk
National Geographic and De Beers
are working together
in a partnership with local
communities
to help protect it.
Developing livelihood
opportunities
so local communities
earn more income from
ecotourism
and raising awareness
of this unique wonder
so it can be protected forever.
By visiting the Okavango Delta
and supporting the people here,
you can help too.
Hire an expert local guide
to walk amongst elephants
and learn more about
how they shape the landscape.
Book the Mokoro Safari
through a locally run operator
to experience the Delta
in a traditional boat, led
by an expert poler.
Or to fully immerse yourself,
book a night under the stars
with the communities
of the Delta.
It will surely be an experience
you will never forget.
Together, we can help ensure
that this lush paradise,
along with the people
and wildlife who live here, can
thrive for generations to come.